all right we're gonna start this week's
uh covet update a little differently
than we usually do we'll start globally
and then
work into the us instead of starting
with the united states because right now
the the global context is increasingly
important to figure out what's going on
because globally cases are actually
almost at a peak right now we're we are
almost
at a pandemic high globally with about
675 000 cases per day which is close to
the
absolute highest point we had uh was
about 745
000 cases per day so thanks to just huge
spikes in some countries and then
small spikes in others we are of
all of this time going all the way back
to whenever we're calling the beginning
february of 2020 or really even earlier
although we didn't know the number of
cases at that time we are essentially
close to the global peak of cases right
now
now it's important to understand that as
more people
get vaccinated cases will mean less and
less
in the sense that a covid case will
less and less likely be something that
results in a hospitalization or results
in a death as more and more people are
vaccinated but the important thing to
understand is that globally we are
nowhere near that point in time right
now of the world's roughly 8 billion
people
only 788 million doses
have been administered and since some of
those
you know or two shot regimens under one
percent
of the global population has been
vaccinated right now
so for now a global case spike
does mean more deaths eventually the
cases right now
are highest in india turkey
here in the united states in brazil
in france and poland those are the top
six right now
so with that is the global context
what's happening here in the united
states well let's now
take a look cases in the united states
sort of level
slight uptick bottomed out around 55 000
a day
now back up to about 65 000 cases per
day
so we are simply in a fight right now
it's variants
and young people going crazy against
vaccines
and we'll talk by the way in the next
segment about what's going on with the
johnson and johnson vaccine which which
is going to be paused at this point in
time we'll get to that
uh but you have places like michigan and
in the northeast of the united states
with the more contagious british variant
increasingly dominant
more and more young people getting the
virus uh and
you you've got that up against more and
more vaccinations that fortunately are
being done
the good news is that this entire time
deaths have continued to decline when
what was it six weeks ago
we saw the case decline level out we
said
we might see death's level out in three
weeks as well that hasn't happened
uh deaths peaked in mid to late january
around 3 500 people
uh dying per day just inconceivable
tragedy
now down to a still tragic but about 80
percent lower
750 deaths per day that
should continue to decline as
vaccination is rolling out
we have not yet vaccinated enough people
to see cases
collapse we are vaccinating enough older
and at-risk folks that increasingly
people getting the virus are less and
less likely to die and that's exactly
why you start
with the oldest and the most vulnerable
some states
and and this is good news and then we'll
get to what's going on with jnj
in a moment some states are only about
a month out from herd immunity
massachusetts is a state for example
where 92 percent of the population wants
the vaccine
more than one percent of the population
is being vaccinated daily
approaching high 30s percent vaccinated
and could be at 70 percent
within 30 to 40 days now for comparison
when
israel got to 50 vaccinated
cases just fell off a cliff went down
very very quickly so that could be
coming in some states
in other states like mississippi
vaccination is happening really slowly
uh not nearly as much interest in the
vaccine
many unscheduled you know appointments
in mississippi that are just remaining
unscheduled and available
so it remains to be seen what happens
there now as far as vaccination
we saw another single day record
of 4.6 million doses on saturday
nearly another 3.6 million doses
on sunday these are really incredible
numbers so the playbook
is keep vaccinating anyone
at risk that you can convince as to
the importance of getting vaccinated
that's great
and then don't go crazy just yet we know
that the pfizer vaccine is less
effective against the south african
variant
the vaccines work well against the
british variant basically just as well
but it is more contagious so that's
that's quite literally a race
the path out is vaccination likely
boosters in the fall
or winter modified for the variants
that's where we are
so we have to keep going at this point
most people i know personally have had
at least one shot even younger
people full eligibility happening
nationwide on april 19th
that's in six days that's all great the
problem now
is what's going on with the johnson and
johnson vaccine so we should talk about
that next
this is not good news and it could slow
down
those really great vaccination numbers
that i just told you about
u.s regulators are now calling for a
complete and total pause
on using the johnson johnson coronavirus
vaccine
because of six blood clot cases
that have happened among six million
people who have received
the johnson johnson vaccine so the first
piece
is that the fda and the cdc uh have
already decided
they will no longer use the vaccine at
federal vaccination sites
they are urging states to also pause and
as far as i know
basically every state is doing it i know
people who were scheduled to get their j
j
shot today their appointment has been
canceled what we know so far
per the new york times is that six
recipients
in the u.s developed a really rare
disorder that involves
blood clots within about two weeks of
vaccination
it's six people all women between the
ages of 18
and 48 one woman
died a second woman in nebraska has been
hospitalized and is in critical
condition
nearly it's actually not six it's nearly
seven million people
in the u.s have received the jnj shot so
far
nine million more doses have been
shipped to states which presumably will
just be held for the time being
dr peter marks who directs the fda's
center for biologics evaluation and
research put out a statement
along with uh the principal deputy
director of the cdc
and shoeshot and they said quote we are
recommending a pause in the use of the
vaccine out of an abundance of caution
so let's talk the numbers through six
incidents out of about
seven million vaccinations the first
question is
was this caused by the vaccine or did
these six individuals
have some underlying disorder or
abnormality
that was exacerbated by the vaccine
other questions that are being looked at
include
given that we're talking about all six
of the individuals
were women age 18 to 48 could this be
connected to some kind of medication for
example and
this is just an example there's no
evidence of this but this is the type of
question that's being asked
if all six of these women were on oral
contraceptives the birth control pill
that would be something to look at we
just don't know yet and while it's been
while it's being investigated it's going
to be a setback in the vaccination
program
everybody is being clear right now that
there is not a causal relationship here
but it has to be investigated in the u.s
somewhere between 300 000 and 600 000
people per year
develop blood clots generally but not
this particular kind of blood clot this
is a cerebral venous
sinus thrombosis it's very very rare and
we have to do it safely that has to be
priority number one
um we also have to make sure that this
is reported on in a responsible way you
know what's going to be on fox news
tonight
uh the anti-vaxxers are already saying
see we were right about
all of it well no you the same people
said
mrna vaccines are really really
dangerous
and it actually it's been the two
adenovirus vaccines
that we are seeing this blood clot issue
with the jnj vaccine here in the us
astrazeneca in europe and in other
places remember that
out of 34 million people who received
the astrazeneca vaccine in britain
as well as the eu and and three other
countries there were
222 of uh these blood clot
incidents linked with a low platelet
level so a slightly different situation
um it's it's been the adenovirus
vaccines where we've seen this
not the mrna and so when the same people
that were talking about
mrna come forward and say all of these
vaccines are unsafe
let's let's not allow them to uh to gesh
gallop us
let's talk now about the effect on just
the vaccination program in the united
states
with the jnj doses we were expecting to
have enough
for all 260 million
adults in the u.s by the end of next
month by the end of may didn't mean
everybody would have received their
shots by then but there would be enough
supply without the johnson and johnson
doses
most adults there would be enough supply
for 230 million adults that's not
everybody that's not all 260 million
but so many people are refusing to get
the vaccine
that in practice even without the jnj
doses
there very well could still be enough
doses for every adult
who wants the vaccine to get one
um and that supply would be available by
the end of may so
we could be depending on how many people
want the vaccine this could be a delay
of a few weeks and getting to where we
hope to get
it could be a delay of a couple of
months there are other countries
that are so dependent on future doses of
the jnj vaccine that
if this doesn't get resolved in a way
that it's deemed to be safe
and the jnj vaccination continues it
could really be a disaster for
the plans of of of some other countries
um the vaccine might also come back
online relatively quickly but with some
demographic restrictions if we can
determine that there's something about
why
it's only affected six women
do you say well we're bringing it back
online but only men should get the jnj
vaccine
this is idle speculation but these are
the things medical regulators are going
to be looking at so
not the news that we wanted
we continue vaccinating with the pfizer
and the moderna vaccines deaths are
continuing down
cases are level and if we can race the
variance successfully
cases should be uh significantly lower
in about a month
and we will continue following what
happens with the jnj vaccine as well as
others distribution
cases variants and all of that let me
know your thoughts
if you've received the jnj vaccine
already but you're within the two-week
period during which these reactions are
happening
are you worried or are are the numbers
so low
that it doesn't concern you let me know
i'm on twitter
deepakman the number one funding source
for the david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get
access to the world famous bonus show
every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpackman.com that's join
pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by
all means use the coupon code better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
the david pakman show is a viewer and
listener supported show
you can get lots of great extras and
support the work that we do
by grabbing a membership at
joinpakman.com we do have a coupon code
available that coupon code is
better21 and you can get the daily bonus
show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show join
is the place this next clip is sort of
funny but it's also
it's it's also kind of sad i don't know
why it kind of got bummed out watching
it
dr anthony fauci was on cnn yesterday
with wolf blitzer
and wolf blitzer tried to make a
baseball analogy
to the pandemic and the analogy was dr
fauci
you like baseball i like baseball if
this pandemic
were a baseball game what inning would
we be in
and dr fauci just seeming exhausted
saying you know wolf this isn't like
baseball but i
i actually think there is a baseball
analogy that could be made that dr fauci
could use in the future
i'll tell you in a second but let's take
a look at the clip where are we dr fauci
as a country right now
in our fight against this virus uh
we're both baseball fans for example
what inning are we in
you know it you know the it's it's not
like baseball
uh wolf because the inning that we're in
is going to depend on how we respond
and that's the issue because i mean if i
say we're in the seventh inning it's
almost over
and we have surges like we're seeing
throughout
europe and the rest of the world and the
threat of a surge that we're seeing now
you know it's not measured in innings
anymore it's measured on what we do
to contain this okay so dr fauci is
correct in the sense that
we're only in the seventh inning if
people behave one way
and otherwise it might really only be
like the fourth inning or the fifth
inning and we have a long way to go here
is me
workshopping a better baseball analogy
tell me what you think about this
you know wolf the pandemic isn't a game
it's really like a world series where
you have to win four games
to actually win so the question is are
we going to sweep this in four
or is it going to go seven because we
don't finish off the virus as quickly as
we could
right that's the baseball analogy what i
can tell you wolf is
we have one more game to win but will it
be a sweep
or will this go seven games right uh you
could
maybe you could even go further game one
testing and controlling the spread
uh game two uh scaling up testing and
researching vaccines game three
developing and testing the vaccines game
four
finishing vaccination to end the
pandemic and then next year
you might have another world series
right variants potentially new vaccines
the other baseball analogy i was
thinking of that might work would be
listen wolf we're in the seventh inning
but the virus is trying to catch up and
if they do
and and we have a tie then we go extra
innings
and as you know wolf extra innings can
go on indefinitely until someone wins
and we don't want that
every time a red state doesn't have
enough people wanting the vaccine
the virus has just knocked in a single
if the virus gets enough of these
singles it's going to start putting runs
up on the board am i going too far with
this
regardless we all share dr fauci's
exhaustion with this
if it's game four and you can finish it
off
or have to play another game you power
through
the exhaustion and that's what we're
hopefully doing with three and a half
million vaccinations a day
we're going to have to deal with the
pause on the johnson and johnson vaccine
over the blood clot fears as i told you
earlier
uh but big picture i mean like do you
think
it's a problem that wolf blitzer and
others use these
whether it's sports analogies or
whatever the case may be
like on one hand there really is no
analogy to something with a defined
duration
because the duration is is whatever we
make it new zealand just stopped this
you could say they walked off the field
after the first inning and said we don't
have to play the rest of the game
because there's almost nothing left to
do they controlled it so well i don't
know i don't know if maybe the sports
analogies or the fight analogies
that are sometimes used maybe it makes
it more relatable
maybe it just makes it more confusing to
people let me know what you think
fox news host tucker carlson is again
facing calls to resign or for fox news
to fire him
and or for boycott for advertisers to
boycott his program
after essentially arguing that the great
replacement theory
sometimes known as the white replacement
theory
is real in the united states but it's
not racist
to suggest it now it's very difficult to
know where to start because there's so
much here
but maybe to set the stage i'll tell you
a little bit about
great replacement or or white
replacement theory
uh this is something that comes from
france originally
in modern times it's become a favorite
of white nationalists and white
supremacists originally
in france it was a theory that white
french people
were being deliberately replaced by
non-european people
including arabs south asians africans
and others
through a combination of importing
people
from those countries through immigration
combined
with white french people being
encouraged to have fewer babies are
having a lower birth rate
now it's just become a very in the u.s
when we talk about great replacement
theory or white replacement theory it's
a popular white nationalist white
supremacist idea
um and it not only is it generally
speaking white supremacist it's also
specifically anti-semitic in some of its
flavors you might remember back in
the charlottesville white supremacist
rally back in 2017
they were chanting among other things
jews will not replace us that's what
this is about that's a reference to
exactly this idea
so tucker carlson goes on and he's
interviewed i think it's by mark stein
and says democrats do want
to replace americans and they want to
dilute the population but it's not
racist
it's just true so let's just jump right
into the first clip
i'm laughing because this is one of
about 10 stories that i know you've
covered
where the government shows preference to
people who have shown
absolute contempt for our customs our
laws our system itself
and they're being treated better than
american citizens now i know
that the left and all the little
gatekeepers on twitter become
literally hysterical if you use the term
replacement if you suggest
the democratic party is trying to
replace the current
electorate the voters now casting
ballots with new people more obedient
voters from the third world
but they become hysterical because
that's that's what's happening actually
let's just say it that's
true so tucker as a good faux populist
or maybe better said as a right wing
populist
he knows enough to avoid saying this in
the way that is
overtly racist he does it more subtly
and with code
when he talks about replacing american
voters with voters from the third world
he's talking about voters that are
mostly brown people or black people
that's it he's using coded language
so not only is this straight up great
replacement stuff it's also it's also
nonsense
and as i've said before trying to win
elections by importing people
who are slightly more likely to vote for
them in seven to nine years
when they get citizenship if they get
citizenship it's a terrible strategy
think of the numbers and this is why you
know we very often react to the rhetoric
and we ignore the sort of factual or
empirical basis
75 million people voted for donald trump
if
naturalized immigrants vote for democrat
60 40 because remember even though a lot
of people like tucker want you to
believe that all immigrants are very
left-wing the truth is
that you know cubans and venezuelans are
not very left-wing
there are lots of uh asian immigrants
that are not left-wing
there are many eastern european
immigrants that are not left-wing anyway
let's imagine that naturalized
immigrants
by a 60 40 margin vote for democrats
that means that for every 500 000
immigrants that become citizens
that's only a hundred thousand vote
margin for democrats
when you compare that to population
growth when you compare that the people
who move between states
it's a drop in the bucket when you talk
about bringing people in
having them wait the five years before
they can request citizenship
and then the additional period to go
through that process
if this is how democrats are trying to
win it's a very stupid strategy
let's continue with the clip if look if
this was happening in your house if you
were in sixth grade for example and
without telling you your kid
your parents adopted a bunch of new
siblings
and gave them brand new bikes and let
them stay up later and help them with
their homework and gave them twice the
allowance
that they gave you you would say to your
siblings you know i think we're being
replaced by
by kids that our parents love more and
it'd be kind of hard to argue against
you because
look at the evidence so this matters on
a bunch of different levels but on the
most basic level
it's a voting rights question in a
democracy
one person equals one vote if you change
the population you dilute
the political power of the people who
live there so
every time they import a new voter i
become
disenfranchised as a current voter now
by that logic
every time a new american-born kid turns
18
tucker's vote is also worth slightly
less
every time an adult dies tucker's vote
is worth slightly more that this is just
life this is inflows
outflows it's not evidence of any kind
of grand
you know grand replacement theory let's
look at just one more clip here
so i don't understand why you don't
understand this i mean everyone wants to
make a racial issue out of it oh the you
know white replacement there no no
this is a voting rights question i have
less
political power because they're
importing a brand new electorate
why should i sit back and take that the
power that i have as an american
guaranteed at birth is one
man one vote and they're deluding it no
they're not allowed to do that
why are we putting up with this so this
is what happens when people
fall for populism in some ways in
rhetoric
people will watch tucker and they'll say
that there's a lot there that sounds
kind of like bernie sanders
there's very there's a similar language
that's being used there
they're for the people they're for the
middle class they criticize the elites
uh corporation sometimes i'm with the
little guy but then tucker goes on a
rant
about third world immigrants deluding
his voting power uh
black lives matter is going to take your
house immigrates make
immigrants make the country dirtier as
he said i don't know if it was six
months or a year ago we covered
it this is the guy that some on the left
are idolizing
saying tucker is out flanking the left
on some issues there's a contingent on
the left that has completely fallen for
this guy
it's incredible stuff and as you know
consequences
for tucker i imagine none that he's at
fox news
to do this type of stuff this is a
feature not a bug
and while he's dealt with some
advertiser boycotts
anybody hoping for some kind of
repercussions to this
do not hold your breath we'll have more
on this story
and others from today's show on the
david pakman show instagram page you can
find us at david pakman show
and if you want to see a very strange
hate mail that i got this morning
follow me on instagram at david.pacman
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
david pakman show today i'm going to be
speaking with
uh mark robert rank who is professor of
social welfare
at washington university in st louis and
also
author of the book poorly understood
uh out now by oxford university press
so great to have you on today oh thanks
david great to be with you
so i mean let's just jump into maybe
what's one of the meatiest
uh uh diving boards into this topic
maybe which
which are the misunderstandings about uh
the poor
in the united states two of which
correct me if i'm wrong
are the misunderstanding that most poor
people don't work
and the misunderstanding that most poor
people are
minorities ethnically or or racially
tell us maybe
how this came about but also the truth
of the statistics
yeah i think you know kind of underlying
those myths
is the idea that uh or the myth that you
know poverty happens to somebody else it
doesn't happen to me
and so you know it happens to folks who
don't work or
folks that are uh minorities um
but you know it doesn't really affect me
it's not gonna happen to me
and what we show in the book is that
actually uh if you look at the majority
the majority
of folks in poverty are actually white
um a majority of or more folks in
poverty live in suburban areas than in
central cities and some of the deepest
seated poverty is in rural america and
the idea that the poor don't work
is simply wrong most of the poor have
have worked in the past and will work in
the future
and it's it's really important to think
about poverty
as something that people go through
they're not poor their whole lives
they hit a spell where they have some
tough times they experience poverty they
may be out of work
but then they get back on their feet and
they will work in the future
so you know i think underlying those
ideas is this
myth that you know poverty is something
that
happens to somebody else and doesn't
happen to me
there's a few different things i think
would be interesting to explore you
mentioned
suburban versus urban is there
how can we quantify and qualify the
difference between the rural and
suburban poverty
versus the urban poverty which maybe is
more the caricature of where the myths
come from
yeah so if you um you know it's
certainly the case that folks in you
know
inner city central city areas um the
poverty rates
are higher than the overall rate
but there's many more folks now that
live
outside of central cities and so in
terms of the number of folks in poverty
you know again it's higher in
surrounding
urban areas as opposed to the central
city and as i mentioned
if you look at some of the most extreme
poverty in the united states it's
actually found in rural america
so areas like appalachia the deep south
and mississippi delta
american indian reservations the central
corridor of california
all of those areas have really really
deep-seated poverty
and that's kind of you know when we have
this image of
of who are the poor we often think about
the poor
as you know non-whites in inner city
areas and it's not to discount
that that poverty exists there of course
but
poverty is much much wider the way i
like to describe it is that
the reach of poverty is really wide but
its
grip is is not that strong people move
in and out of poverty a lot
what are the most common reasons that
people
who at some point were not poor end up
in poverty which maybe is different from
transgenerational poverty where you're
you're born into poverty and remain
there
is there an interesting distinction to
be made there there is so
um the folks that are um
long-term in poverty is about 10 to 15
of everybody who will experience poverty
so about 85
of people who experience poverty do so
for a fairly short period of time and by
short i mean
a year or two now why do they experience
poverty
it's because things happen to people
that they didn't anticipate
like losing a job a family splitting up
getting sick a pandemic occurring all of
these things have the potential
to throw people into poverty for a short
period fairly short period of time
now what's interesting about this is
i've done a lot of work in the and the
book focuses on this right from the
get-go
of the question of what's the long-term
likelihood that an american at some
point will experience
poverty right it turns out that between
the ages of 20 and 75
60 of americans will experience one year
below the official poverty line
and three quarters will experience
poverty or near poverty
and the reason is because again over a
long period of time things happen to
people
that can throw them into poverty and
when that happens there's not a lot
in place to protect them how how much or
is that number at all skewed to
um people in their very early 20s
in college who are technically in
poverty but it's not really reflective
of their situation
yeah that's a great that's a great
question and that that's a question that
we
we often get on that research and so
what we did is we took out um
those folks and we did the analysis and
found that it
it it it varied um it didn't change very
much
i mean the number of people that are
actually in graduate school you know
that might sort of fit that sort of
starving student picture
um is actually pretty small and so it
doesn't really affect the numbers very
much at all
graduate school and presumably college
uh juniors and seniors right i mean 20
21 yeah it's so it's rel it's not a huge
doesn't change the numbers dramatically
it doesn't change that when you
again when you look over a 30 or 40 year
period it really doesn't change it very
much
when it comes to the i mean i i it may
go back before this actually maybe
that's a good good question
for me some of the big historical
markers
of when the narrative around the poor
started to resemble what it is now i
think back to
the reagan era the story of you know the
welfare taking cadillac
queen having kids in order to get food
stamps
how far back does that trope sort of go
well i think you're right that that kind
of the modern version of that really
started with ronald reagan but the idea
of the deserving and the undeserving
poor actually goes back
400 years to sort of england's poor laws
at the time but certainly ronald reagan
was the one in in more modern times that
really emphasized that
and the argument that he's making it was
making
was using those stereotypes to argue
for smaller government you know his big
line one of his lines was
you know government is not the the
answer government is the problem
that we fought a war on poverty and
poverty won well it turns out
that well-constructed government
programs actually have a very
significant effect on reducing poverty
so take the war on poverty uh in 1959
the poverty rate in the united states
was around 22 percent by 1973 it was 11
we cut poverty in half because of the
war on poverty and because of the strong
economic growth during that time
so did we eliminate poverty no but it's
an example that government
actually can be quite effective in
reducing poverty
so in terms of reducing poverty i mean
the the you there are some
uh poverty inducing factors that are
similar around the world
and there are some that are that are
less common you know
medical expense bankruptcy doesn't exist
in many countries
it does exist in the united states so
this this understanding that this may be
hard to parse out
when we talk about poverty discussions
often
include all of the following and more
minimum wage
access to health care improving
education
cost of living rising wage gap
uh on and on and on what
interventions have been shown to be the
most effective at cutting poverty
well i think the number one
number one solution is
jobs that can pay a decent wage jobs
that provide a livable
wage and also having benefits associated
with those
so what has happened in the united
states over the last 40 or 50 years
is we've been producing more and more
low-wage jobs
and jobs that don't provide benefits and
so
a median male worker who is full-time in
the labor market
today is earning slightly less once you
control for inflation
than he was earning in 1973. there's
been a huge stagnation
and that's one of the reasons why more
and more people are at risk of poverty
because they're working at jobs that
just can't support a family
so i think that's the number one factor
that we need to focus on but as you
point out there are many other factors
as well
such as you know having access to health
care
child care good education those are all
really key elements to
addressing the issue of poverty when we
think about
stimulus like the kind we've seen now
three times during the course of the
pandemic
or a proposal for a fifteen dollar
minimum wage which
the sort of more free-market-minded
folks would say
these are these are artificial um
decisions that are being imposed the
minimum wage would be a price
floor on labor that might be above what
the market would dictate or just
dumping a one-time payment on people is
not really going to systemically change
the value of their work to an employer
or whatever the case may be
what do we know about the longer term
impact of those types of interventions
yeah interesting so first of all uh the
idea of
providing kind of a monthly universal
payment to
families with children has been going on
in european countries for decades
and it's shown that that's really really
effective in terms of reducing the rate
of childhood poverty
and uh in the uh in president biden's um
pandemic package we have
a version of that where you know every
family with a child would get three or
four hundred dollars
a month um so we we are actually
starting to get some research in
on the effect of this type of a of a
policy there's a there was a study that
just came out from stockton california
that did kind of a universal basic
income and they actually showed it had
really positive effects and
interestingly
it actually the folks that were getting
the ubi actually had
higher rates of employment than those
who weren't
because that's one of the fears that you
know this creates a work disincentive
actually it creates a lot of positive
incentives in terms of people
you know being able to live what i often
refer to as a livable life
the mobility question is an interesting
one where there's a bunch of ways to
measure
how likely it is that if born into
poverty one will exit poverty and you
can look at this at a country level you
can
parse it out by education and race and
all of these different things
for those who are born into poverty
but get out of it what do we know about
the following
generation the kids of those folks and
their likelihood of remaining out of
poverty as well
yeah so the way i like to think about
this is that
it's the notion of cumulative inequality
so first of all as i said most folks who
experience poverty do so fairly short
periods of time but they may not get
that far above the poverty line yeah
um but the way the way we we often like
to think about the united states is that
there's a level playing field and you
know everybody's kind of starting at the
same point
and i use the analogy in the book of
actually what's going on
is a modified game of monopoly
oh this is interesting now i i've used
this and i think i've used this analogy
before and i'm wondering where you first
heard it actually
well i i thought i came up with it but
oh that's interesting
wow but i i don't know we'll tell it to
us because let's see if it's the same
one i use yeah
okay so you know we we normally think
about a game of monopoly we have three
players everybody starts out with
fifteen hundred dollars
yep they go around the rules of the game
apply and you know
luck and chance and skill um determine
who's going to win the game
but now let's look at an altered game of
monopoly where player one starts out
with five
thousand dollars player two starts out
with the fifteen hundred dollars and
player three starts out with two hundred
fifty dollars
and we're still going to have the same
rules uh
and and and abide by those but
who's going to win most of those games
well given
the prior advantages player one
is going to win considerably more even
if he or she is not as lucky or as
skilled
okay um and the other point is that
player one can play the game differently
than player three they can take more
chances
if player three makes one mistake it's
over
and and that's what's really going on in
this country is we have an altered game
of monopoly where some players are
starting out with that five thousand
dollars
more and more players are starting out
with maybe a thousand or fifteen hundred
and uh unfortunately many people are
starting out with the 250 dollars so
we really we need to think about how can
we
address some of these prior advantages
and disadvantages
so that we have more of a sense of the
quality of opportunity which we often
talk about as important in the united
states
right so we're at the end of our time
but my so my
version of the analogy is yeah it's
almost the same it's
everybody really does get the same
amount of cash but the late starting
players have to contend with all the
properties already having hotels on them
absolutely and so but it's it's really
the same idea that's very interesting
yeah yeah no that that is we've been
speaking with mark
robert rank professor of social welfare
at washington university in st
louis the book is poorly understood
which we will link to
um in the youtube video for for our
conversation today
mark really a pleasure having you on oh
this was great david i really enjoyed it
the david pakman show is now on
instagram at david pakman show you can
check out
behind the scenes pictures memes
shots of the studio shots of what pat
does
all day very very concerning to a lot of
people all of that and more on the david
pakman show
instagram account at david pakman show
so we're still
still in the process of learning about
the police shooting
that left dante wright dead in brooklyn
minnesota
not brooklyn new york brooklyn minnesota
and yesterday
police had a press conference about it
one of the strangest police
press conferences i've ever seen in the
middle of it the brooklyn police chief
tim gannon
just walked out he later returned there
were
questions as to why did he leave and the
answers were
very strange what we know is that police
shot
and killed a black man on sunday during
a stop for a traffic
violation there have been protests there
has been unrest
i've looked at the video of the shooting
which we will not be playing
here but you can find it online we know
that the officer
announces that she will be tasing
but then she pulls out her gun and
shoots the individual
apparently and this is the case that you
will see made during this press
conference mistaking her gun for her
taser
which uh is immediately raising
questions about
how could that be called an accident if
you are a police officer
it's your sort of main thing to know do
i have
a taser in my hand or do i have a gun
are these my hand
handcuffs or is this a soda uh but we're
going to get to that
the man killed by police was identified
by relatives and by minnesota
governor tim waltz as dante wright 20
years of age
nbc reports that the state mobilized the
national guard when crowds
gathered in front of the brooklyn center
police department on sunday evening a
curfew was ordered it's been chaotic
let's get into the clips one of the
strangest video
police press conferences that i've ever
seen here's the first part where chief
tim gannon says listen the officer
announced the taser but drew her handgun
that sort of seems like the officer
meant to tase dante wright
not shoot dante wright as you can hear
the officer while struggling with mr
wright shouts taser taser
several times that is part of the
officer's training prior to deploying a
taser
which is a less lethal device that is
done to make her partners aware
as well as a subject that a taser
deployment will be imminent
during this encounter however the
officer drew their handgun
instead of their taser for informational
purposes
we train with our handguns on our
dominant side
and our taser on our weak side so if
you're right-handed you carry your
firearm on your right side and you carry
your taser on the left
this is done purposefully and is trained
as i watch the video and listen to the
officer's commands it is my belief that
the officer
had the intention to deploy their taser
but instead shot mr wright
with a single bullet
this appears to me from what i viewed
and the officer's reaction in distress
immediately after
that this was an accidental discharge
that resulted in the tragic death
of mr right so the officer yelled taser
and was distressed so therefore
it was an accident and that's the
statement from the police chief now
what the police chief calls an accident
by the law
could be manslaughter and this has been
ruled a
homicide remember homicide can be murder
but it can also be manslaughter brooklyn
center minnesota police chief tim gannon
was asked
did you authorize the use of tear gas
and rubber bullets during the protests
he essentially says yes was it your
decision to release tear gas and to
um suit fire bullets no um rubber
bullets as a
young protester sure this is i'm the
police chief in this city
police action is made by me the decision
is made by me
did that answer your question then a
reporter says
you know if the reason for the stop was
not having a license plate or having an
expired license plate
are you aware that there's currently a
multi-month
delay on license plates here and the
police chief
just walks out of the press conference
significant delay
are you aware that there's a significant
delay in getting
tabs and things of this nature from the
dmv so even people who have purchased
tabs are unable to get them because
there's a two to three month backlog
are you aware of that and is your staff
also aware of that
and have you made any type of
recommendations to your staff
to be mindful that we're in the middle
of a pandemic and don't pull people over
for tabs
particularly because there is a
significant delay in getting those tabs
from the the department of motor
vehicles are you aware of that
i am worried about the police i am aware
that is your staff aware of that
yes they are that was the last question
i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry mr mayor matt asked you
in that video a female officer clearly
made a fatal mistake
so this was very abrupt bizarre he just
walks off
and the brooklyn city manager appears to
be unable to explain why that happened
mr mayor when i asked that question
about
the firing of the police officer the
police chief left
what is that an indication of is he
dealing with something perhaps more
important or
or is that some type of silent protest
because he left immediately
immediately i can't speculate mr mayor
you have a comment
does that bother you without knowing why
that he just walked out
i do not know why the chief left um you
know it
i can only speculate as to why uh
why he left it you know at the time that
he did
what would your speculation be
i i don't i don't have any speculation i
mean it's it's possible that
you know the chief uh you know takes the
position
uh perhaps similar to the city manager
that you know there needs to be
uh you know some some kind of a process
or um you know i i don't know
i can only speculate and i believe from
the amount of coffee
i saw him chug he needed to empty his
bladder like how
how odd is all of this stuff now then
here is where it gets even crazier
the police chief comes back did someone
tell him off screen
that looked terrible get back out there
so he's back and then he says the
officer needs due process
yes sir yeah ask you directly as i ask
the mayor
do you believe the officer who fired
this fatal shot and i understand there's
due process we get that
but ultimately she shot and killed a 20
or 20 year old man
the mayor has indicated she should be
terminated
what's your position on that my position
is that officer afforded due process
just like anybody else does
she has the right to be heard she has
the right to give her statement
she has right to tell what she felt what
she thought not what
not what i thought not what i saw but
what she thought and what she and that
may have an impact
she's on administration time one time
out she will she will not be she will
not be returning to duty
until this investigation runs course and
she for all intents and purposes
i think we can look at the video and
ascertain whether or not she'll be
returning
so everything the chief says there is
correct of course the officer
does get due process they should be on
administrative leave
and they are that's not the issue the
issue is more this guy's bizarre
attitude demeanor
walking out walking back in now i'm
already getting a ton of emails from
people saying
this officer is going down this is clear
manslaughter they're going down for
manslaughter others saying
they're not getting anything here i i'm
going to give you my
both non-legal expert and cynical
opinion
about this case i believe that this
officer
will not be found guilty of any criminal
wrongdoing
i think that you will either see as far
as criminal goes
something settled resolved an agreement
before this ever gets to trial
or if it goes to trial you will see an
acquittal
and you will see a civil settlement for
big bucks
with the family of dante wright why do i
say this
there's no question that if you mean to
tase someone
and you pull out a gun and you kill them
uh
that's manslaughter colloquially
speaking
but the way that police
shootings are handled in the legal
system
with the taser warning they will they're
already pulling the games of well you
know this is someone who had a run and
he had a
i think it was a warrant for some minor
drug related thing
they're gonna pull out all the games
that they normally do
i'm not giving you my moral opinion i'm
giving you simply my prediction
i think that we will see uh no
guilty verdicts criminally for this
officer
and likely a big financial settlement
with the family
it's going to be a long time could be
years before we ever get to that
resolution
but that's uh that that's my sense at
this point in time tell me your thoughts
we now have new allegations against
beleaguered
republican congressman matt gates we've
already discussed his alleged
involvement in child sex
trafficking and or possibly paying
minors
for sex there's a whole world of scandal
for matt gates related to that
but now there's a totally new problem
for him he is suspected of being
involved in a shill
candidate scheme now a shill candidate
scheme or a ghost candidate scheme
is one where if i'm running or if my
friend is running
i might induce or help someone
else run not because i want them to win
but because i want them to siphon off
votes from my opponent
and i'll explain exactly how it worked
in this case
in florida's 37th and 39th districts
alex rodriguez and celso alfonso
ran for office one of the candidates has
already been charged the believed
mastermind is a
guy called frank r tiles a resigned
florida senator
and now we've learned of a third shill
candidate named justine ianati
who ran in the ninth district in florida
all three of these candidates appear to
be funded by the same dark money
through a pack called our florida pack
and a pack called
the truth pack for central florida
both pacs are funded by a single
untraceable atlanta company called
proclivity
that made only one expenditure to a
printing company called advance
impression it's all weird
and the matt gates piece is that gates
appears to be connected to that central
florida
aspect of this and the idea is that
justine ianati
ran as an independent to help the
republican jason brodeur
win by taking votes away as a
left-leaning independent from the
democratic candidate patricia
sigman every aspect of this is imploding
florida lobbyist chris doorworth who is
the person that talked to matt gates
about the shill candidate justine ianati
resigned on friday
from his lobbying firm now it's
important to understand
it doesn't appear that the being
involved
with creating a shill candidate is
illegal the criminal part and
we're still learning this is my best
reading as of right now the criminal
part would be the dark money funding all
of this
and uh it's basically just a spoiler
scheme
that appears to be legal as long as it's
funded legally and transparently
and the idea is if i'm a republican and
i'm running against a democrat and it's
expected to be tight
50-50 it could come down to a half point
i go out
and recruit a left-leaning independent
to run
so that they will siphon votes away from
my opponent and i as the republican win
that's the strategy in a sense this is
what trump was doing
with the reports that people around
trump were advising and encouraging
kanye west to run
the the belief being if kanye runs
it'll take votes away from joe biden and
it'll be good for donald
trump it's a slimy practice it's not a
new one it appears to be legal as long
as you do it
in the particular way where the funding
is transparent democrats could do this
democrats could do this by starting to
register and help libertarian candidates
run across the country you might have a
tight senate race could be 5149 for the
republican
you bring in some freedom free market
libertarian
and then if they take three points from
your opponent you win
um that's the idea will matt gates
ultimately get arrested for something
or is he going to escape scot-free for
everything he is suspected of
let me know your thoughts i have a
voicemail today which you can leave me
anytime at 219 to david p
this is again we talked about
enlightened
uh enlightened right-wingers who believe
that they are enlightened
here's a right-winger who believes that
he has a balanced view
of the riots and of the election being
stolen and all of this stuff let's take
a listen this is interesting
you know hold on
yeah how this message is for david um
i'm sitting here
watching your show day and you're
talking about
this poor old baby about her beliefs on
whether the election was stolen or not
yeah why don't you just be honest with
about it
instead of instead of being so
patronizing towards people
you know what we saw that night was
water mains breaking in georgia so the
water main georgia story has been cited
often
there doesn't appear to be anything odd
about it and remember the election
didn't come down to georgia so you've
got to take it piece by piece
uh they had to stop counting people for
being kicked out
so they had to stop counting different
states have different rules
about counting hours they were
pre-determined
people being kicked out people who had
no you can't just go and tour
you know like it's uh like it's a uh you
know a local park
places where votes are being counted
there there are actual observers but the
people that showed up in michigan for
they had no right to be there you know
as far as we knew at 1 30 trump was 80
to win that is not is so that's not true
but more importantly for months we knew
about the red mirage
early votes in person would go trump
later votes would go
we knew that ahead of time and then they
act like it's some big shock when it
happens
you know and everybody wakes up in the
morning and and sees it completely
flipped
so that's the story you know this person
believes they're a critical thinker but
that's just the story trump told and
this guy fell for it 30 4 o'clock in the
morning
and in the in the silence of the night
you know that's again you know the idea
of massive dumps of ballots in the
middle of the night
and so look it's not that people are
believing donald trump about anything
really because you seem to have
basically repeated trump's
ideas verbatim in this voicemail we're
believing
our eyes you know so
yeah so anyway that's that's a balanced
rational
trump supporter who just repeated all
the same tr stuff
trump has been saying for five months at
this point we've got a great bonus show
for you today we will talk about the
progressive movement demanding that
justice breyer retire
we will talk about prageru's latest
target kindergarten
and we will talk about new zealand
passing miscarriage
bereavement leave law uh
very interesting all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show
get instant access to the bonus show by
becoming a member
at joinpacman.com